How do you define reality?
That's a tough one.
So I would say most of you define reality
like you're Isaac Newton or maybe like
your Democritus who was the first
person who hypothesized Adams.
And so in the Newtonian world,
it's like billiard ball world,
right?
Everything is made out of little billiard
balls and they bang together in a
causal way and you can predict the
consequences of their banging together.
And if you extend it enough,
you can conjure up an
entirely deterministic world.
A happens causes B,
B causes c always the same way and
everything runs like a giant clock.
That's Newton's model.
And,
and it was a clock model because you know,
back at that time,
clocks,
man,
those things were pretty damn impressive.
Clocks got the whole industrial
revolution underway and you know,
medieval cities would put an awful lot
of time and work into their clocks and
they thought those damn
things were really cool.
You know,
they could keep track of
where the planets were moving.
It's like that's a big deal at Clark.
And then if you want to think about
an invention that changed the world,
it's like the clock's a big one.
Now we can measure time in the same way.
Everyone can measure time.
It's a big deal.
So the idea that the
universe is like a clock,
given that the clock can
predict the universe,
it's a pretty damn powerful idea.
It turns out that it's
wrong because you know,
causalities a mass,
no one really understands it.
And there are levels of analysis that
which causality just in the way we
experience it doesn't seem
to imply it apply at all.
You go down to the subatomic level,
it's probabilistic.
You can't predict single events.
And I don't believe that
you can predict the future.
You can predict parts of the future
in an extremely limited way for some
purposes,
for some span of time that,
and you can't even predict how long
that span of time is going to last.
You know?
And some things seem to be more stable
across more situations and more times
than others,
but there's still,
there's instability everywhere and
it makes it predicting things a very
difficult thing to do.
So.
Okay,
so that's one idea about reality.
That's the idea really,
that you have,
and that's the reality that
you've been educated to have.